when kumail nanjiani was cast in
marvel's eternals he was determined to
step up his game to play the samurai
kingo suen and challenged himself to
look the part here are the secrets the
star and his personal trainer grant
roberts have revealed behind his bulking
up journey
after seeing kumail nanjiani's photos of
his physical transformation plenty of
people wondered how he got those
incredible results and if they could
potentially recreate his success on
their own however nanjiani has been open
about the fact that his results would
not have been possible if he wasn't in a
position of immense privilege he worked
with personal trainers and nutritionists
throughout the year all of whom were
focused on creating a custom program for
his body goals and lifestyle nanjiani
wrote in his instagram caption i would
not have been able to do this if i
didn't have a full year with the best
trainers and nutritionists paid for by
the biggest studio in the world i'm glad
i look like this but i also understand
why i never did before it would have
been impossible without these resources
in time
over the course of his fitness journey
kumail nanjiani worked with many top
personal trainers and nutritionists all
of whom played an important role in
helping him achieve his goals but he
spent most of his time training with
grant roberts who has also worked as an
actor you might have spotted him in
sully or in films like million dollar
baby being in front of the camera
himself meant that he understood exactly
what nanjiani needed to do in order to
prepare for eternals roberts told page
six my process is completely
individualized and starts with the
gathering of information current
lifestyle body composition tests etc i
also have a 3d scanner that's
particularly useful for goal setting and
strategizing the nutrition and training
program the 3d body scanner that robits
uses probably doesn't come cheap but
these machines create accurate pictures
of his client's body composition posture
and how their measurements change as
they work out it was an invaluable tool
for creating nanjiani's training program
he scares me oh me too but he's an
excellent motivator
that's true what are you looking at
so if you want to get muscles like
nanjiani how often do you have to hit
the gym nanjiani generally worked out
for a little over an hour four to five
days a week however recovery time was an
important component of his fitness
program he consistently took two or
three days off each week many people
think that they need to push themselves
to work out without taking a day off if
they want to bulk up or lose weight but
having scheduled rest days so that your
muscles can heal is actually crucial
roberts definitely wanted nanjiani to
commit to a rigorous workout schedule
but as a professional trainer he also
understood that regular rest days would
be the key to long-term success spending
time relaxing outside of the gym is just
as important as spending time in the gym
they say that abs are made in the
kitchen and this was definitely true for
nanjiani getting fit wasn't just about
burning calories in the gym he also had
to ensure that he was fueling his body
with healthy foods sure you can
technically lose weight while eating
sugary desserts or savory comfort foods
but when it comes to building muscle you
need to start with the right building
blocks and put nutritious foods on your
plate what was included in anjani's food
pyramid he went with the low-carb
approach to dieting he also made sure to
eat plenty of protein which is essential
for building muscle and having a
sustained source of energy for workouts
nanjiani also focused on adding healthy
fats to his diet particularly sources of
omega-3 fatty acids in addition he made
sure to drink plenty of water and stay
hydrated if you're exercising as often
as he was you don't want to forget your
water bottle when you go to the gym
many people find that sticking to a
consistent healthy diet is even more
difficult than finding a form of
exercise they enjoy but for kumail
nanjiani this wasn't the case he was so
dedicated to his fitness program that he
didn't want to take cheat days in fact
one of the nutritionists he worked with
basically had to force him to take a day
off from his diet and indulge every once
in a while nanjiani credits david
higgins for giving him permission to
enjoy his favorite foods and stop being
so hard on himself what did nanjiani
reach for on cheat days he grew up in
pakistan and he loves pakistani food but
he admits that this cuisine is very carb
heavy which meant that it wasn't
appropriate for his usual meal planning
but he says that traditional pakistani
food like biryani non-bread and rice was
his quote go-to cheat meal and he would
often feel so full after eating it that
he had to take a nap afterwards
when roberts designed nanjiani's workout
program he had a philosophy in mind no
weak spots yes they would target certain
muscles but overall he wanted to create
full body workouts his goal helped
nanjiani look like a real bodybuilder he
encouraged najiyani to concentrate on
the symmetry of the musculature so that
he would see improvements all over
roberts admits that he pushed nanjiani
in a way that he had never been pushed
before but nanjiani was always up for
the challenge robert says that nanjiani
was genuinely enthusiastic about getting
fit telling men's journal i was excited
to work with kumail because i could tell
he was ready to dedicate himself to the
process i have literally thousands of
text messages to prove that point
getting these kinds of results doesn't
happen without maximum effort
when it comes to helping his clients
roberts clearly likes to stay on the
cutting edge and utilize new technology
in the world of fitness while working
with nanjiani roberts regularly used
electric stimulation or e-stem to target
certain muscles the average gym goer may
not have used this tool but apparently
celebrity trainers like roberts are big
fans so how does electric stimulation
work basically roberts would place pads
hooked up to electric wires on
nanjiani's back over specific muscle
groups sometimes he would deliver a zap
which helped quote fire up the muscles
it may sound strange but roberts is a
fan of using this method with clients he
used electric stimulation with nanjiani
about twice per week
when you start working out and eating
healthy you don't see results overnight
the waiting game is frustrating but it
takes a while to notice the results you
really want however according to roberts
non-gianni really didn't have to wait
long to see results this is because
roberts went right in with workouts that
were focused on intensity packing lots
of action into a short time frame this
leads to fast muscle building and weight
loss which was probably quite motivating
for nanjiani roberts told page six
kumail responded very quickly as most
people do when introduced to training
that shocks the system whether it be for
fat loss or muscle gain or as in
kumail's case both when nanjiani started
working out to get ready for eternals he
felt like he had spent years holding
himself back from his full potential he
had generally worked in comedy he was
best known for silicon valley in the big
set but he knew if he wanted to try
something different he would need to
transform his physique he had no idea
just how strong he could get because he
had never tried to figure out what his
physical limits were at one point he was
getting so muscular that marvel told
roberts and nanjiani to scale back and
slow down a bit apparently he looked
quote too big and too cut for the roll
therefore roberts lightened up on
nanjiani's workouts this probably wasn't
the kind of feedback that nanjiani
expected from the studio but it had to
be flattery
[Music]
how'd you feel
taller
the key to seeing amazing results in the
gym isn't just physical exercise it's
also about your mindset kumal nanjiani
said that his perspective and sheer
level of concentration on his goals were
necessary to achieve the look he wanted
he told men's health when i'm exercising
i'm not thinking about anything else
it's like meditation nanjiani even
admitted that some of his friends were
dismayed by his new attitude towards
working out he says that at one point
they essentially quote staged an
intervention to get him out of the gym
for a few days they were worried that
his intense focus on working out would
detract from his skills as a comedian
nanjiani knew that outlook might affect
his work on funnier projects but he said
that in the end he didn't care i'm kind
of obsessed with it being funny wasn't
his only priority anymore he was ready
for a major change and he was willing to
accept the sacrifices that would come
along with it
in order to achieve the results he
really wanted nanjiani's nutritionist
basically had to micromanage his diet he
had to be exceptionally careful about
eating sugar and whenever he ate
something sweet he had to give them a
heads up so they could plan his meals
accordingly nanjiani told men's health
they were like if you're going to have a
can of coke today let us know in the
morning so we can adjust and account for
it although he was allowed to enjoy
cheat days he soon found that after
eating such a clean diet all week long
going on a sugar binge during the
weekends would hold him back when he
returned to the gym nanjiani admitted
that on one particular occasion he
decided to indulge in sticky toffee
pudding but came to regret it the next
day saying that he felt so quote off
that he had to endure 12 hours of
physical pain he eventually got so
strict with his sugar intake that he
ended up going an entire year without
eating even a single brownie
there's a common mistake that people
make when they begin working out they
try to go all out and adopt some extreme
habits which inevitably don't stick as a
personal trainer roberts is well aware
of these pitfalls and he was determined
to help nanjiani avoid them instead
roberts made sure that nanjiani was
developing habits that would be
sustainable in the long term even after
he dialed back on his original intense
training schedule roberts told the
hollywood reporter we sent him away in
peak physical condition but he's had to
maintain that i give him kudos for being
able to do that especially when he was
working it looks like the new nanjiani
is here to stay he's come a long way
throughout this journey and there's no
doubt that his skills will impress
audiences when eternals premieres
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite celebrities are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]